I used to have some really spirited but
enjoyable conversations with people who
had a totally different world view to me
but in their own way they were Noble
they wanted to build a better way as
they saw it and I'm talking about
you know people from the serious left as
the left was then it was about
universalism let's lift the
disadvantaged up so they're part of the
family and some of those people will say
say now their own movement is so
distorted it's now about creating an
aristocracy of victims and then
weaponizing them it's never about
solving their problems because you
solved their problems they're not
victims and you lost your weapon and
what a terrible thing to do to other
people
and and somehow we've got to rebuild
that respect
and it's the same with uh with with
something like private property we
should respect I mean on the Four
Freedoms free speech to my way of
thinking freedom of conscience and
belief freedom to associate and and
freedom to earn private property
including
your intellectual prowess you know
you're using yours in fact it's yours
it's not for a government to come along
and shut you down or take away your
private property or whatever it's yours
to use wisely well
you know weaken any of those freedoms
and you weaken them all it's like a
four-legged stool you know you break one
and still will fall over
but we don't talk like that anymore and
Australia in particular has fallen
victim to this which I know because when
I was growing up I saw these Aussie
blokes as being these kind of ruggedly
masculine dare I say to masculine right
loving a punch up in a beer and whatever
else and now you've got Melbourne which
I mean is is it the wokest place on
Earth practically
wow
um there are Regional differences in US
[Music]
doesn't come out yeah
um
yeah well you know it is extraordinary I
I was in America recently and I had a
two-hour interview uh with Patrick Bett
Davis uh in in Miami and he called the
show whatever happened to the
Australians
and I don't know how many Australians
understand that you know that we've got
this image now around the world of of
the most severe lockdowns and you can
only walk for an hour a day why not you
know an hour and one minute you know and
why not five and a half kilometers away
from home instead of five kilometers and
then you know pregnant women being
dragged Away by police and what have you
one Facebook post and this pregnant
woman is now in deep trouble you're
under arrest in relation to incitement
incitement what's that what on Earth
excuse me what what on Earth just put
your found in can you like in my pajamas
what's this ultrasound yeah she's
pregnant so you can take it easy what's
this about ultrasound in an hour let me
finish simulation to a Facebook post in
relation to a lockdown protest that's
why I'm arresting you Innovation how can
you arrest her that's for my two
children she could face a jail sentence
of up to 15 years
but they voted for more of it sort of
Stockholm syndrome you know the the the
regime that put it in place has been
subjected to an election and they want
it again partly because the opposition
didn't stand for enough but partly
because people
who was the American forefather I think
was Benjamin Franklin that people who
become afraid and go looking for
security over Freedom are worthy of
neither
I think we've lost sight of how valuable
Freedom which is why I've enjoyed my
conversation so much Constantine with
you as we've talked in the past about
your home environment and you've written
this marvelous book which I really you
sent it to me and I really you know it
survived the British and Australian
money it arrived at home on my farm in
northwest New South Wales and I read it
and I thought isn't this terrific
because you can see as so often those
who are sitting in the luxury spot when
everything else seems comfortable
how our own slothfulness is placing at
risk the very things that we enjoy
foreign